c'est connu les pesticides les parasites
et les maladies des cibles les colonies
d'abeilles un peu partout sur la planète
mais un nombre grandissant d'études
montrent du doigt la diète de ces
insectes c'est pollinisatrices se
retrouve de plus en plus souvent dans
des déserts alimentaires ce qui met en
péril leur survie
ces employés préparent des milliers
d'abeilles à aller au combat
la bourdonnante armée aura pour mission
d'envahir deschamps à ses risques et
périls
l'apiculteur à celle vaches et prend
soin de renforcer les lignes de défense
tu vois ici on une colonie qui est plus
faible que celle ci s'est clôt ce que je
fasse que je vais retirer de carl pour
la rendre sensiblement de la même force
que l'autre qui est juste à côté
il s'assure également d'avoir le nombre
requis de ruches pour son client un
producteur de bleuets de la région
auparavant c'était majoritairement des
abeilles sauvages qui féconde et les
plans d'une multitude de cultures en
butinant elle transportait le pollen
d'une fleur à l'autre mais depuis
l'industrialisation de l'agriculture
leur nombre a considérablement diminué
certains apiculteurs ont pris le relais
avec des abeilles domestiques qu'il loue
le temps de la floraison dans les
bleuetières la pollinisation commercial
augmente la mise à fruit de 70 à 100 %
mais la pratique est loin d'être aussi
profitable pour la santé des abeilles
car les bleuets tiers sont de vastes
monoculture c'est un peu comme ullmann
qui lit pendant plusieurs années il
mangerait que la même chose
après quelques semaines seulement il y
aurait déjà des des problèmatiques
alimentaire y aurait déjà des carences
de protéines c'est la même affaire pour
la veille c'est certain que ça amène un
affaiblissement du système immunitaire
il faudrait tout revoir le modèle agro
alimentaires partout dans le monde
entre-temps et on n'a pas le choix il
faut y aller avec les abeilles et c'est
pour ça qu'on veut trouver des mesures
pour les aider dans leur travail
cette étudiante en biologie qui est
également apicultrice s'est penché sur
l'impact de la pollinisation commerciale
sur les abeilles
elle a comparé l'état de santé de
plusieurs colonies
le premier groupe dans un milieu
agricole dont la flore étaient
diversifiés un second dans une
cannebergière et un dernier dans une
bluette hier première constatation dans
les champs de bleuets
même s'il ya suffisamment de nectar il
n'y a pas assez de pollen donc de
protéines pour nourrir les abeilles
on a vu que le développement du couvent
qui sont en fait les yeux
les laves que la reine bon diminuait et
c'était significatif
parce que si la colonie n'est pas en
mesure de reprendre ce développement le
on a des colonies - forte puis l'hiver
arrive et c'est la catastrophe
ça nous mais c'est l'énorme stress sur
les épaules parce que à chaque année on
prend des ententes avec les producteurs
de bleuets pendant l'hiver puis quand
qu'on arrive au printemps on s'attend
vont certain nombre d'heureux c est là
tout à coup hop on se rend compte qu'on
n'a pas le nombre de ruches qu'on
voulait raphaël vacher perte de 20 à 25%
ses abeilles parfois même 40% durant
l'hiver
par la suite les colonies se renouvelle
en 40 jours si leur état de santé le
permet
au printemps l'apiculteur prépare donc
ses nouvelles recrues à affronter la
saison de pollinisation en leur donnant
des galettes de protéines des vitamines
et des minéraux
1 ce que ça amène réellement une séance
c'est là que je peux certains je le fais
mais j'ai aucune certitude
aujourd'hui ces grands départs les
abeilles sont transportés à girardville
le client un petit producteur de bleuets
est là pour accueillir la précieuse
cargaison vélo
[Musique]
le lendemain matin
les abeilles sont à l'oeuvre la saison
de pollinisation coûte 15 mille dollars
aux producteurs
oui c'est une grosse dépense mais ses
ruches sont vraiment bonnes
on les voit ni afin qu'un juge ait battu
record à 1 passe et là aussi le facteur
situe à cause de leurs affaires comme la
pollinisation se fait aux dépens de la
santé de ses abeilles
raphaël vaches et suggère maintenant à
ses clients d'établir des airs de
butinage c'est à dire des eaux florales
diversifiée aux alentours des bleus et
hier le premier réflexe qu'ils ont c'est
que pour eux ça va être une perte de
surface perte de cultures donc une perte
de production mais une perte de
production à court terme peut devenir
quelque chose de gagner à long terme
dans la forêt j'ai des cerisiers avec
toutes les plantes à fleurs
son but n'est parlée je crois même pas
que je devrais investir ces deux jours
là dans la nature du genre c'est je
regarde à long terme a fait que cindy
garde mais une terrasse la journée en
mettant une terrasse pour vos à bègles
[Musique]
une zone de butinage spécialement
aménagé pour les abeilles
pierre fortes y en a une c'est l'un des
seuls producteurs de canneberges à avoir
pris cette initiative dans le centre du
québec ont compris que c'est majeur le
problème des abeilles au québec
il faut absolument que les mentalités
changent
ce qu'on appelle un montant qui fait que
c'est la perfection
y'a plus rien à manger aujourd'hui c'est
jour de livraison
un camion vient porter 800 ruches
l'apiculteur sirella perry teste une
nouvelle formule pour améliorer la santé
de ses abeilles
cette année on a utilisé pour la
première fois des probiotiques
on a regardé ce qu'ils avaient sur le
marché et puis on a pris ce qui nous
semblait le meilleur cette saison 6
l'apiculteur n'a pu livrer que 40% de la
commande initiale malgré tout pierre
fortier qui pèse 750 mille dollars pour
la location d'abeilles est content il
sait que le recours aux abeilles
augmente de 50% la mise à fruit des
canneberges sirène jamais nous touchons
des battle tag cette année madame mais
moins massive hier c'était 17 ce matin
23 c'était chouette année est très bon
c'est quand même
la nature c'est ici
malheureusement les millions d'abeilles
qui sont relâchés ici et dans les autres
chantent canneberge de la région souffre
encore plus que celle qui s'activent
dans les bleus et hier les plus mal en
point et c'était d'ailleurs une de nos
hypothèses c'était celle qui était allé
en canneberge
non seulement il ya peu une entrée de
lecteurs mais les abeilles devait aller
dans leurs réserves
et puis ont vidé leur viseur et c'est
vraiment la disette est long plus de
carburant et plus rien qui rentrent le
problème c'est que les cannebergières
sont des monocultures situées dans des
territoires dont la diversité florale
est encore plus pauvre que celle des
bleus est fière les analyses ont révélé
que seulement 9% des écosystèmes située
dans un rayon de butinage de 3,5 km d
cannebergière fournissent un bon
potentiel d'alimentation aux abeilles
même si les canneberges sont peut-être
une source
une excellente source de protéines pour
elle mais c'est que ce qu'elle mange
donc celle aucune déficience puis bas si
on le voit dans les résultats de la
santé de l'abeille l'hiver suivant leur
contrat les abeilles ont donc davantage
de virus que celles qui ont fait
uniquement la pollinisation du bleuet ou
encore pas de pollinisation
on va sortir des canneberges bellon être
sur une ruche qui est en pente
descendante et non importe le montant
dont pour la production de miel c'est un
impact presque immédiat c'est difficile
on voit jamais le bout du tunnel dans le
fond parce que le but ultime c'est nous
à ce qu'on fait en premier tout c'est la
production de miel
à la mi juillet quand la pollinisation
est terminée la colonie tente pour la
deuxième fois de la saison de se refaire
une santé
si tout va bien les abeilles profite du
restant de l'été pour produire du miel
en plus grande quantité que pendant la
saison pollinisation mais cet été la
production de miel a été catastrophique
pour plusieurs apiculteurs de nombreuses
maladies ont décimé les colonies même
celles qui n'avaient pas fait de
pollinisation commercial alors où les
ruches sont en dormance pour l'hiver
certains apiculteurs réfléchissent au
choix déchirants qu'ils devront faire le
printemps prochain empoché l'argent des
contrats de pollinisation
alors que la production miel n'est pas
commencé qu ils ont peu de revenus ou
tenter de préserver la santé de leurs
colonies en les gardant uniquement pour
la production n'est elle saurait être
décidées sont fait plusieurs
pollinisation payant poupaud donc
peut-être qu'on va laisser tomber la
canneberge
on le sait pas encore je connais des
gros apiculteurs qui sont en train
d'abandonner
je connais plusieurs petites fermes
petites bêtises apiculteurs aussi qui
arrivent à la même conclusion que dans
le contexte mondial économique dans
laquelle on est c'est en devient très
difficile de rentabiliser nos
entreprises
le danger de pertes de colonies de
dissimulation maladie ça peut mettre en
péril aussi le programme de
pollinisation commercial est ce qu'on
est capable de trouver une façon de bien
sustenter les apiculteurs qui vont en
pollinisation commercial soit capable de
faire ça à long terme
les apiculteurs sont à la croisée des
chemins
[Musique]